I was teaching at University of Texas
and I was teaching a class in
interactive design and,
and this was in the sort of late
nineties and the Internet had had gotten
really big and my students were
grappling with notions of interface
design and really trying to figure out
what,
how to,
how do they engage users.
Um,
and so I brought in a project where we
began to study games and the students
began to design and redesign games as a
way to understand what is good
interactive design.
And that is the first time that I'd
actually brought games into my own
classroom space.
And the first time that I took people
who'd never done game design and put
them in the role of a game designer,
and it was a huge moment of discovery
for me because my students learn more
about how to engage an audience,
how to really communicate and how to
create really interesting,
unusual kinds of spaces when they used
game design as a starting point,
even though they weren't designing
games.
Eventually the process of thinking like
a game designer gave them a whole tool
set,
this tool set that they hadn't had
previously.
Um,
and so that sort of set me along this
path where I began to say,
you know,
there's something just interesting in,
in this act of teaching people to design
games.
Um,
and then I began to work with kids.
And one of the most interesting thing
that happens when you work with young
people in designing games is how deep
they go into the content.
And so this is this question of where
the math and science,
um,
stuff might come in.
When we look at kids and we talk about
that definition of who is a Gamer,
it's actually a really old definition.
There used to be a time when only a
certain population of kids played games
and they tended to be boys and they
tended to be kind of Geeky boys that
were hidden away in their basement.
The truth is today when you look at who
was playing games,
particularly younger kids up to about
sixth or seventh grade,
it's all kids.
Um,
and most kids don't self identify
themselves as gamers.
If you ask them about that identity.
Um,
it's just something that they do.
So there's an assumption when we recruit
kids for the school that,
that all kids have to a greater or
lesser degree,
some experience playing games and an
interest in playing games.
The school is not,
excuse me,
it's not a vocational school that's
intended to graduate game designers.
So that isn't actually any way that we
talk about the school.
Um,
and so the kids that we get,
our kids that are deeply interested in,
um,
a school that might feel a little bit
different than a traditional school,
um,
they tend to be really creative kids,
that are,
um,
interested in ideas that they'll have a
chance to design stuff and make stuff.
Um,
they're kids that tend to be,
you know,
in some sense,
um,
high performing and having strong
interests.
And those interests don't necessarily
have to be games,
but they might be interested in reading
or they might be interested in sports,
but they're kids that get passionate
about something,
um,
and get excited about a school that
might help them cultivate that passion.
So at the model at quest is that the
teachers collaborate with game designers
to design the curriculum.
So there's no expectation that teachers
have to be game designers in the way
that there's no expectation that the
game designers are going to be in the
classroom teaching day to day with the
kids.
Um,
so the teachers that we recruited mostly
came from the public school system.
We have a couple that taught at private
schools previously.
Um,
none of them had a game design
background.
Uh,
a few of them had an interesting games.
Some of them had a background in
technology,
um,
but all of them were strong
collaborators,
had worked in context where
collaboration was key.
All of them were deeply interested in
the craft of,
of learning and,
and how to really work with kids.
Um,
and all of them were open to the idea
of,
uh,
being a curriculum designer and,
working with game designers and trying
to see where this model could,
could really take learning for kids.
I would say that it's not so much among
our parents,
um,
because any open house or talk that they
might come to you where they hear about
the school becomes really clear how
we're talking about games and how we
value them.
But there is a larger cultural
discourse,
um,
that I think is quite limited around
this issue of what's the value of games
and what's the value of play and video
games in particular because they've been
covered I think historically in the
media
as either a games that are about
violence or games that are about wasting
time.
Those are the two kind of dominant
narratives that people that don't know
much about games here again and again
and again.
And so it's a bit of a default
position that people fall into just
because they haven't perhaps really
thought about it.
Um,
any parent that,
that we have that has a child that
spends an amount of time gaming at home
actually understands something about why
that child is gaming and what they're
getting out of it.
And partially it is because they talk to
the kids.
Um,
and those reasons really vary.
Sometimes the,
the value of the gaming is,
uh,
around the,
the social structure and the community
that the kids have.
We find that that gaming is less about
the artifact of the game itself and more
about the community that sort of sits
around that game and that players are
part of.
And for many parents that social piece
is pretty big for kids.
Um,
for other parents,
there is a opportunity around creativity
that they see happening in these games.
They also see their kids persisting on
problems and games that they don't see
them persisting on another other spaces
and they begin to recognize that that
persistence and tenacity is actually
something pretty important.
They don't really know how to make it
happen in other kinds of spaces,
but they see their kids doing that and
they think,
wow,
if I can get my kid to do that when
they're working on math,
be that persistent.
There's something really valuable there.
Um,
so I think it's more this general
cultural dialog that's pretty,
um,
pretty narrow and pretty underdeveloped
at the moment.
And in part of the goal of this school
as well as some,
you know,
a lot of other people doing work in this
space is to try to complexify the
argument,
um,
and begin to understand that,
you know,
historically from the moment that human
beings sort of came into existence,
play was a part of culture.
It was a profound part of what makes us
human,
a profound part of what keeps the
community together.
A profound part of ways in which we can
deal with complex issues that are maybe
too complicated to deal with outside a
kind of play space.
Um,
and so the,
the notion and value of play
historically has been huge and it
doesn't make sense to me today why we
would dismiss it.
Um,
because it's something that we see
embodied in a way that maybe we don't
understanding and understanding some
digital games that,
um,
for many people look kind of scary.